will you hit me B right now am i off
today I feel like I'm on a little bit
looks like I'm off but I don't feel like
I'm off I feel like I'm okay
I stop I'm off on board with anus foot I
just don't think that's her Jam we've
said it before I think that's what it is
I don't leave like I only she likes when
we repeat things
oh yeah it's a thing of mine yeah but
also I find that it's necessary because
when I go to other podcasts I repeat
myself so Who am I to say anything oh I
did Eric Griffin's podcast last week hi
how was the chemistry I went all the way
to the other side of town for it yeah he
lives in Century City it's insane
yeah you're like underneath like all
those under passes it's like it's insane
it's really far yeah I go what are you
living here and you go in it and it's
like a time machine right babe but
Eric's not making fun of them we're not
what he loves you and your brother so
deeply yeah you I should be nicer to him
there's something off about what when
you see a guy who's a stand-up
television you know films and that and
you go into his kitchen and they have
like that poster with the dogs gambling
over Dangerfield right but like those
are like a classic sign the others are
classic signs or there's something wrong
going on like if I flipped over that
thing there's bloodstains right or like
a message that says greed in blood yeah
it's starting in the sevens no it's not
right it's starting like he's that that
kind of guy I can't corroborate this yes
you can no I can't you will because
we're gonna break into his house and
we're gonna get fingertip prints
fingertips and prints all of it
he's killed somebody he has done
something that house is unnatural
anyway anyway go ahead I only mention it
because I wanted to defend him and I
think his home is a very normal cozy
home yeah he's like a real person he has
office supplies but you know it's so
weird when you think of someone as a
very like 2d you don't think of them as
real because you just see have a very
well he does their podcast he's very
funny to me when you go into their home
and you look at you know
pens that they buy ya like the post-its
no a reminder you go your laundry fold
it and you're like wow yeah did you go
new his kitchen I did did you go into
his this little storage place where you
put them like the Parmesan cheese and
all that kind of I didn't the pantry or
the pantry thank you that were thank you
all right well go in there all right
did you see the little little bottle
there that doesn't seem like it should
be there press on it Oh lever oh it
opens what's going there's stairs
I wonder what's down here you go down
there and there's a white guy all right
just hear me out right and a woman okay
doesn't married no they don't know each
I'm not married yeah yeah woman's dead
oh I forgot to say that so the guy's
been dead for a long time yeah but the
guy still there right and he's just like
you don't know if anyway nothing and now
we're getting into territory we're gonna
have to cut some stuff out mention
something that he told me and I want I
want to know what you think about it go
ahead so Eric thinks that I should that
there's a part of me that has completely
shied away from like my sexuality that I
no longer when he says when I when I
first met you you were just so you know
you had you were using sexuality and
then now you you know you dress like
slow basically and so he was saying you
know maybe you should walk around the
house with like basically he's telling
me to wear it she lingerie around the
house don't think that that's that I
should put out a thirst you deserve
better
oh you deserve you deserve better let's
get to that that's what you took yet
let's get let's get to the fruit let's
get to the room I'm so great listen I
know
I'm listening everything you're saying
that's what I'm saying what I'm saying
he's saying that I should do more
exactly I should do more I should do
more and I apologize I got to be better
you know what I'm saying
all right what you're basically saying
is is that what Erich is saying changed
you right over the years and now I have
you in some sort of mind controlled or
mind meld kind of a situation just let
me hear just let me think let me think
out loud yeah your mind
good I think that's where the magic is I
think out loud right yeah I think that
he's saying some [ __ ] that like I
somehow you know unfeminist you is that
even a word and it is now yeah through
time and that you used to wear yeah you
used to be Tanner used to be a little
bit more I don't either
you used to be a little bit more like
ditzy you mean but you're a brute the
smartest person I know you're the
brightest person I know
you're the most complex person I know
you're everything to me babe so you can
listen to that fat black [ __ ] flap yeah
that flack [ __ ] all right all you want
I'm gonna [ __ ] now and people go use fat
shaming him doesn't that have you seen
his body yeah if you have eyes you have
eyes you've seen it then there's
something wrong unhealthy okay stop
drinking grease oh my god I'm going core
too far help you love him not what he
said I loved him and he was saying but
no I'm kidding back check that fact I
love oh you're right I'll get better
babe I'll be a better person you deserve
something better she just deserve better
a better boyfriend
I'm the worst no you know we deserve to
be better for each other I need to be
better too there we go that's all I
wanted to hear he said a victory we're
doing it - you're doing it together
yeah